Hello world, it's Saroj and let's
visualize some data, shall we?
There was a refill lab study where
a group of scientists straps some
participants what they
fitness tracking device.
Then ask them to do a bunch of
exercises while recording some physical
measurements.
And I've got that Dataset,
will visualize it in a two d graph so
we can make some discoveries from it.
We live in a three dimensional world,
so we can understand
things in one dimension,
two dimensions and three dimensions pretty
easily. But data can be complex. AAF,
sometimes data demands that we tried to
reason in hundreds or even thousands of
dimensions at some
fundamental level are puny.
Biological brains just can't do that.
So we've invented machine learning to
help us learn patterns in our data that we
can't recognize ourselves.
Take Alphago for example,
because they could reason about
so many possibilities at once.
It made moves that seems strange at
first to the world champion it played
against, but then it ended up beating
him by doing that or IBM's Watson.
It consistently diagnosed cancer better
than the best doctors because it was
able to analyze millions of
cancer research papers at
once and match a patient's
genetic profile to what it had learned.
And there are so many things that
ml hasn't yet been applied to.
So opportunity is right
and turns off the satellites for you.
We'll launch his own gym satellite,
we're going to collect that data.
Our
exercise data is kind of complex as well,
but we're going to figure out how to
visualize it so that we can understand it.
So let's take a look at this data.
Each row represents a different person
and each column is one of many physical
measurements,
like the position of their arm or forearm.
And each person gets one of five class
labels like sitting or standing that
represents the activity they've done.
So there's a lot going on here,
but you'll notice that some of
these cells have empty value.
So the first thing we'll want to do
is clean our data by removing them.
Let's first import pandas,
which is our data analysis library.
That will help us read our CSV file.
Then we'll import num pi to help us
transform our data into a format our model
can understand.
Psychic learn will help us create our
machine learning model and map plot live
will eventually help
us visualize our data.
Now that we've imported our dependencies,
we can use pandas,
read CSV function to download that
exercise Dataset directly from the Web and
store it and the data frame all variable
and we'll also create a variable to
store the number of rows in the data by
calling the shape function on the zeroth
column.
To get the count of rows,
we'll call the is no function than the
sum function to get the total sum of the
no or empty columns in our dataset.
Then we'll create another variable to
count the number of non empty columns in
our dataset using the previous
variable as a parameter.
Now we can remove the columns with missing
elements by only using the non empty
columns. Also, if we look at our data,
the first seven columns don't have
information we can use to differentiate
between our classes,
so let's remove them as well.
Using the I x function which asks for
the index of columns we want to delete,
we'll specify from the up two column
seven we're going to take this clean data
and transform it into a set of vectors
which we can then feed to our learning
algorithm.
A vector is a set of numbers and it's
how we represent data in machine learning
will create directors to represent the
features for each person in our data.
Let's grab all of our features from our
data and store them in a variable we
call x.
Then we'll want to standardize those
features using the standard scaler object
of psychic learn.
In math terms,
this means shifting the distribution of
each feature to have a mean of zero and
a standard deviation of one,
which is a way of saying make all the
features operate on the same scale so they
are all in proportion to one another.
This will improve.
The quality of our results will store
the resulting 70 dimensional feature
vectors and the ex STD variable.
Since 70 is the number
of features we have,
haven't seen India trying to understand
this data set. Each feast is dimension.
Then the note f correct.
If each feature equals one dimensions,
that ain't no sweat check in
heartbeat, that's easy. If it goes up,
then there's a threat, but behold, once
that adds time and it goes up and down,
when I add temperature,
we can move it all around,
but weight and height and strength
and a hundred more features.
I can't visualize that. I'll get me a
seizure. Let's reduce dimensionality,
the two or three so we can see
and understand this data set.
He's the lead data city.
There's an entire subfield of machine
learning called dimentionality reduction.
The Amsa let us represent high dimensional
data in a twoD or three d space.
Even a picture can be considered to have
32 million dimensions if we consider
every single pixel to be a dimension,
but it can also be considered
to have just two dimensions,
length and width of a photo.
We just need to find the intrinsic load
dimentionality hidden in our data so we
can visualize it. One of the most popular
ways to do this is called [inaudible],
which stands for distributed.
The castic neighbor embedding
say that three times fast go.
TSMC will allow us to reduce our
vectors dimentionality to just to,
it does this by taking each one of
our 70 dimensional feature vectors and
finding the similarity between
it and every other vector.
The similarities are represented as values
and stored in a similarity matrix and
then creates a similarity matrix for the
projected map points which will contain
our final representation of the Dataset.
Our first similarity matrix represents
where we are in our second represents
where we ideally want to be.
We can minimize the distance between these
two matrices using a process known as
gradient descent.
This will slowly bring down
the dimensionality of our
first similarity matrix by
updating its values over time.
When it's over,
we can use the trained matrix to
map the points into the space.
We'll initialize our t snd model via
psychic learn and set the number of
components to to this perimeter is asking
how many dimensions do we want our end
result to be in.
We'll fit it on our feature vectors
and store the resulting two dimensional
feature vectors and the x test two
d variable. Now that we have that,
we can plot our points on a two d graph
by first creating a legend for our class
labels and plotting each
point using map plot live.
We'll define the location of
our legend and show our graph.
We can see here that point of the same
class tend to cluster together and r,
t s and d helped make that happen without
knowing the classes of the feature
vectors,
we fed it.
It learned how to represent the
similarity between these classes in a two
dimensional space.
We can further analyze this plot to
study why certain classes are clustering
together and what
conclusions this gives us.
Like these two classes are near each
other since the actions are similar.
So perhaps the more movement and exercise
requires the farther away it will
cluster from the rest.
There are a couple of live demos
of Tsne on the web as well,
like this one that visualized
as a bunch of tweets.
You can see that similar sounding
tweets tend to cluster together,
so to break it down high dimensional data
is everywhere and machine learning can
help us understand it.
If we were dosed the dimensionality
of our data to twoD or Three d space,
we can visualize it ourselves and Tsne
is a popular dimensionality reduction
techniques that you can
use via psychic learn.
The challenge winner for last
week's video is Keegan Taylor.
He can use tensorflow to train a neural
net to classify Pokemon by their type
and the classifier had a
75% accuracy after training,
which is pretty incredible one than anyone
else had bad ass of the week and the
runner up is Michelle Batu,
very well documented and clean code.
This week's coding challenges
and use Tsn to visualize it.
Game of Thrones Dataset that all provide
and write down something you discovered
once you visualized it,
you're getting up submission should go
in the comments and I'll announce the
winner next time, please
subscribe. And for now,
I've got to make my new year's prediction.
I mean resolution.
So thanks for watching.